okay so you know how I said that this
lesson was going to be the one where
we're going to add a sign-in button well
it turns out I lied this lesson is where
we add in all the frameworks and all the
linker flags and do all the random setup
stuff we have to do before we add the
sign-in button but I promise after this
we'll be adding a button it'll be really
exciting so let's get into adding our
frameworks now the first thing we're
going to want to do is download the play
games SDK and the Google+ SDK we're
going to make use of both of these
libraries in our application so first
thing we're going to do is go to
developers.google.com/jobs and once that
page pops up we're going to go to the
downloads link here on the left now on
this page you'll see a link to the games
SDK by the time you see this tutorial
this will probably say version 11 you
can click on this link and this will
download a zip file to somewhere on your
local drive once that's done you're
going to want to follow this Google+ iOS
SDK link and this will take you to the
downloads page for the Google+ platform
if we scroll down to the bottom you'll
see a link for the Google+ iOS SDK and
we can download this zip file as well
once that's done you'll have a downloads
folder that looks a little something
like this we've got our Google+ SDK and
our play game services SDK and so first
thing you're going to want to do is
unzip each of these and then I suppose
we can Trash the zip files just to clean
up a little space great and now we have
some frameworks we can add to our
project now we're going to leave this
play game service ole own for a little
while but let's explore what's in our
Google+ iOS SDK you'll see in here we've
got a couple of frameworks along with a
bundle file and this open source
directory along with the changelog
readme file and some sample code for the
purposes of our application we're going
to want to add the two frameworks into
our Xcode project
so the easiest way to do that is let's
go to Xcode and we can simply drag these
two framework folders into our Xcode
project so i'm going to copy over the
google open source framework folder and
depending on your setup you may want to
copy these into your destination folder
or you might want to leave this
unchecked if for instance you have a
centralized location where all of your
libraries are going to be then you can
have multiple applications all referring
to the same directory and at some point
in the future when you need to update
this directory this framework you'll
only need to update it in one place on
the other hand if you need to put
everything into a nice standalone folder
that you can zip up and send around
maybe it's worth copying this into your
destination folder in my case I'm going
to leave this check and copy everything
over and then I'm going to do the same
thing for the Google+ framework and
again I'll leave this checked make sure
that the guest my number target is
checked as well and look at that we've
got two new frameworks added to our
project I'm just going to move these
into the frameworks holder and we can
take a minute to talk about the few
things that we're not adding you'll
notice we have a Google+ bundle file
that we're not going to copy over this
contains all the resources needed to
generate an in-game Google+ sign-in
button and for reasons that I'll explain
in a future lesson we're actually not
going to take advantage of this we're
going to generate our own but if you
were to use the official Google+ sign-in
button you would also want to copy over
this bundle in addition there's an open
source folder this open source folder
contains the source code versions of
everything that is in your Google open
source framework folder the framework
folder tends to be a little easier to
add into your application you just kind
of drag it in your done but I know that
some developers like to have the open
source folder with all the source code
added to their project they might want
to do this so they can get in there and
debug what's happening if they're you
know program is running into issues
going off into the open source library
there have been a few bug workarounds in
the past I've had to implement where we
actually needed to alter or add things
to the open source folder instead of the
four
work so there may be times you want to
do this however in our case to keep
things simple we're just going to stick
with a framework but feel free if you'd
like to add the open source directory
instead you definitely want to add one
or the other don't add both or my guess
is you'll end up with a bunch of those
duplicates symbol errors so the next
thing we're going to want to do to get
this library to work is add this kind of
obscure linker flag into our project so
I'm going to go to this target and under
build settings I'm going to search for
linker and here other linker flags I'm
going to double click this and add
capital obj capital C as our linker flag
you need to do this to get the
frameworks working and if you're working
how would I ever figure out that this
flag needs to be set for things to work
this is all available on our
documentation we walk you through all
this step by step on the iOS quick start
guide so please be sure to check that
out if you ever need a review of what's
going on in this video so we're going to
add that and then the final thing we
need to do is add in our custom URL type
if you'll recall from our presentation
we need to register with the system that
calm cool gets my number colon slash OS
to call back is a URI that corresponds
to our application and the way to do
that is in Xcode in a feature that maybe
you've never used before which is adding
custom URL types so let's show you how
to do that go back to Xcode and in the
info tab this URL types drop-down will
expand we can hit the plus sign to
create our own custom one and this
identifier will be your bundle
identifier which in my case is con
google gets my number but in your case
probably has your own company name
instead of google and we'll add the same
thing for a URL scheme so just copy and
paste that and we can leave
that that's good enough at that point
we've now basically told the system hey
if you see any URL that begins with com
google gets my number instead of HTTP or
mail to that means go to our application
and finally let's add a few other
frameworks we're going to need so go to
your build phases tab and under a link
binary with libraries hit the plus sign
and we're going to add system
configuration framework we can also add
security framework and then let's add a
few other frameworks that we don't need
for sign-in but we're going to need for
the games sdk and a couple of lessons so
I'm going to add core data framework i'm
going to add cortex duck framework and
finally let's add quartz core framework
you can drag all these two frameworks
folder just keep everything nice and
neat and there we go the setup steps are
finally gone and now in the next lesson
for real honest I promise maybe we can
add a sign button
haha